Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Manu travaille
pour une grande enseigne de mode.
« Bonjour, Hubert Motte.
Dans notre entreprise, nous avons à cœur
les sujets environnementaux.
Pourriez-vous intervenir
pour parler d’écologie ?
- Pourquoi pas ?
Mais quels sont vos projets
et vos ambitions sur le sujet ?
- Eh bien, figurez-vous
que d’ici l’année prochaine,
nous lancerons
une petite collection de T-shirts
faits avec 30% de bouteilles
en plastique recyclées.
Et puis, d’ici 2024, tous les cintres
de nos magasins
seront en plastique recyclé. »
Face à l’urgence climatique
qui nous touche toutes et tous,
la solution de Manu,
c’est recycler.
Et ils agissent tous ainsi.
Qui a déjà vu, dans nos rues,
ces grandes publicités
de différentes marques
qui mettent en avant le recyclage ?
Nos bouteilles sont recyclées,
nos capsules sont recyclables,
nos tee-shirts comportent 30%
de bouteilles en plastique recyclé.
Alors c'est quoi le problème ?
Le problème,
c’est que le recyclage, ça pollue
et qu’on essaie
de nous faire croire l’inverse.
Re-cyclage.
Si on en suit la définition,
cela consiste à remettre dans un cycle.
Un déchet recyclé
redevient sa matière d’origine.
Mais alors, des bouteilles en plastique
qui finissent dans un T-shirt,
ce n’est pas vraiment du recyclage.
Ben non, on appelle ça du dé-cyclage.
Après avoir été une bouteille
puis un morceau de tee-shirt,
le plastique, lui, ne pourra pas
être remis dans un cycle.
Il a une grande chance d’être brûlé
ou mis dans une décharge,
comme plus de 70% des vêtements
qu’on jette chaque année en France.
Et entre nous, il y a plus écologique,
n’est-ce pas ?
Alors, cher Manu, chers amis ici présents,
désolé de vous décevoir peut-être,
mais il y a une réalité :
plus on recycle et plus on pollue.
Notre fameuse bouteille en plastique,
si on veut réellement la recycler,
il va falloir
la collecter, la trier, la broyer,
la mélanger avec du plastique neuf
pour en faire une matière solide.
Ensuite, il va falloir la reteindre
et enfin la remouler
en une nouvelle bouteille en plastique.
Tout ça, ça demande des camions
pour gérer le transport,
des usines et des industries
qui ont un gros impact carbone,
et de l’extraction de pétrole,
pour refaire du nouveau plastique
qu’il va falloir réinjecter
avec le plastique recyclé.
Bref, vous l’aurez compris,
de la pollution.
Et entre nous
il y a plus écologique, non ?
J'ai une autre révélation à vous faire
Le recyclage à l’infini,
ça n’existe pas.
Recycler consiste à détruire une matière
pour en faire une nouvelle.
À chaque fois qu'on la recycle,
elle perd en qualité.
C'est un peu comme au cinéma, finalement.
Prenons un film comme « Les Visiteurs ».
Vous avez tous vu « Les visiteurs » ?
Le premier, il est de qualité,
il est plutôt bon, j’ai trouvé.
Mais les suivants, ça se dégrade un peu.
Pour le recyclage de déchets,
c’est un peu pareil.
Il y a deux solutions :
soit on réinjecte de la matière première,
comme notre fameuse
bouteille en plastique,
soit on lui trouve une application
de moins bonne qualité.
Nos canettes en aluminium
dans lesquelles on boit du soda,
lorsqu’elles sont recyclées,
ne redeviennent pas des canettes
mais vont plutôt être diluées
pour faire des trottinettes.
Et là, j'ai Manu au bout du fil.
« Bon, ok, Hubert,
le recyclage, ça pollue.
Mais c’est quand même mieux
que de produire du neuf. »
Et je suis d'accord avec lui.
Il a raison, Manu.
Mais quand on regarde de plus près,
le recyclage est un alibi
pour continuer à consommer toujours plus.
Et s’il y a une chose à retenir,
c’est sûrement celle-là.
Plus on recycle, plus on consomme
et plus on jette.
30% de bouteilles en plastique
dans un T-shirt,
c’est quand même mieux que rien,
c’est mieux qu’avant.
Notre nouveau T-shirt aura un impact
écologique moins important que l’ancien.
Mais si on cherche à en fabriquer
deux fois plus qu’avant,
là, c’est beaucoup moins.
Et c'est là le cœur du problème.
En nous proposant des produits recyclés,
les entreprises réduisent l'impact
écologique de chacun des produits.
Mais le non-sens, c'est qu'elles cherchent
à en vendre toujours plus,
donc à en produire toujours plus.
Et en fin de compte,
ces entreprises polluent toujours plus.
Et souvenez-vous des publicités
qu’on a dans nos rues,
elles essaient
de nous faire croire l’inverse.
Ou plutôt, elles essaient
de nous donner bonne conscience.
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
d’acheter un produit
parce qu’il était recyclé,
sans forcément savoir
si vous en aviez besoin ?
« On s’en fout, il est recyclé. »
Lorsqu'un produit nous est présenté
comme plus écologique qu'un autre,
on pense qu’on peut en consommer plus.
On appelle ça l'effet rebond
et des scientifiques l'ont démontré.
Ils ont mis deux groupes
dans deux salles différentes,
leur ont donné le même
nombre d’objets à chacun
et du papier-cadeau
pour emballer les objets.
Au premier groupe,
ils n’ont rien dit de particulier.
Au deuxième groupe,
ils ont expliqué que lorsque
les cadeaux seraient déballés,
le papier serait collecté
pour être recyclé.
Figurez-vous que le deuxième groupe
a utilisé 20% de papier en plus
que le premier.
Avant de m’intéresser à ces sujets,
je pensais que le recyclage
allait nous permettre
d’extraire moins de matières premières
chaque année.
Hélas, ce n’est pas vraiment le cas.
Depuis que le recyclage existe,
chaque année, on extrait deux à trois fois
plus de matière qu’on en recycle.
Répondre à l'urgence climatique
en misant tout sur le recyclage,
c'est être en plein naufrage.
Et plutôt que de se mettre à fabriquer
un radeau de survie ensemble,
c'est se mettre à jouer de la musique.
Ça me rappelle
une sombre histoire, d’ailleurs.
Revenons à nos moutons en laine recyclée.
Le problème avec le recyclage,
c’est que les informations
ne sont pas toujours claires non plus
et que chacun présente le sujet
selon ses propres intérêts.
J’imagine que vous savez
ce que veut dire ce pictogramme
qu’on trouve sur les produits
qu’on consomme.
Moi, comme plus de la moitié des Français,
j'imagine que le produit a été recyclé
ou au moins qu'il est recyclable.
Ben non, ce pictogramme veut seulement
dire que l’entreprise a payé un organisme
pour recycler ou brûler
ou mettre dans une décharge,
bref, traiter la fin de vie du produit.
Et des décharges,
nous, Français, on en remplit
dans le monde entier.
Rien qu’en 2020, on a exporté
plus de 12 millions de tonnes
de déchets à l’étranger.
C’est comme si on prenait nos poubelles,
comme ça - excuse-moi Manu -
et j’allais chez le voisin
et je les lançais par-dessus la haie.
Il y a plus écologique, non ?
Malgré tout ce que je viens de vous dire,
tout le monde pense que
le recyclage est la solution.
On consomme et on pollue
toujours plus chaque année
et notre planète est
de moins en moins viable.
Alors on fait quoi avec tout ça ?
C’est la question
que je me suis posée en 2017.
Je venais d'être diplômé d'une école
d'ingénieurs, un peu comme la vôtre.
J’avais travaillé trois ans en alternance
dans une grande entreprise
qui fabrique des vêtements
et j’ai bifurqué.
Depuis ma colocation lilloise,
j’ai lancé l’aventure
et la marque « La Vie est Belt ».
Avec des pneus de vélo usés,
des tuyaux de pompier crevés,
des pneus de voiture,
des cordes d’escalade,
on fait des ceintures,
un peu comme celle-ci ;
avec du linge de maison en seconde main,
des draps, des housses de couette.
on fait des caleçons, des culottes.
Les déchets qu'on revalorise
ont eu une vraie vie avant.
Et à la différence du recyclage
ou du décyclage,
on ne vient pas détruire la matière
pour en faire quelque chose de nouveau.
On réutilise les produits tels quels,
les déchets tels quels.
On découpe les pneus de vélo,
on les lave et on travaille avec ça.
Pour les draps, c'est pareil.
On appelle ça du surcyclage
ou de l’upcycling en anglais.
Pour la confection, on travaille
avec une entreprise à Tourcoing
qui participe à des emplois
de personnes en situation de handicap
et avec un deuxième atelier
solidaire à Roubaix
qui permet la réinsertion professionnelle
auprès de personnes éloignées de l’emploi.
Je vous montre ce que ça donne.
Pour vendre nos produits,
on ne fait pas de publicité,
on ne fait pas de soldes
pour pousser à la consommation.
Notre entreprise est rentable
et nous n’avons pas
d’actionnaires externes.
On est cinq dans l'équipe.
On a revalorisé plus de douze tonnes
de caoutchouc, plus deux tonnes de coton.
Et aujourd’hui, ça participe à
sept emplois solidaires en France.
Ça va faire cinq ans qu’on existe
et la vie est Belt !
Imaginez.
Imaginez, vous êtes assis à une table
avec neuf autres personnes autour.
Au milieu se trouve de la nourriture.
À vous dix, vous allez devoir subvenir
à vos besoins avec ça, avec ce qu’il y a.
Il n'y aura rien de plus.
Chers amis, au lieu d’être dix,
nous sommes sept milliards.
La table, c’est notre planète
et la nourriture au milieu,
ce sont les ressources limitées
qu’il nous reste à notre disposition
pour garder notre monde viable.
Les utiliser intelligemment
est la solution.
Intelligemment.
Et si finalement tout se trouvait là ?
Trouvons les idées, soyons créatifs,
changeons les schémas
qui ne conviennent pas.
Et d'expérience, c'est hyper stimulant
que de changer des manières de faire.
Revenons au plaisir de la sobriété,
dans nos vies perso,
mais surtout dans nos vies pro.
Fabriquons des produits plus solides
qu’on pourra garder dans le temps,
s’échanger ou revendre, comme la marque
Loom, qui fait des vêtements durables,
ou comme Kippit,
qui fait de l’électroménager incassable.
Partageons ce que nous avons,
troquons, revendons.
Pour ça, des plateformes et des lieux,
vous en connaissez plein.
Emmaüs, le réseau des friperies, Vinted,
Geev, Nobuy, Smile, Troc et j’en passe.
Revenons au bon sens :
des produits en vrac, de la consigne,
comme toutes ces épiceries zéro déchet
ou comme les concepts du Drive tout nu,
ou de Jean Bouteille,
ces entreprises qui démocratisent
la vente de produits sans emballage.
Chers politiques, obligez nos entreprises
à produire certes mieux,
mais surtout moins.
Emmenez dans la danse avec vous
les citoyens et les commerces.
La ville de Roubaix, dans le Nord,
en donnant des composteurs à ses habitants
et des contenants réutilisables,
a réduit par deux
la quantité de déchets ménagers
en seulement cinq ans,
Réparons ce que nous avons déjà,
comme le permettent les plus
de 2 000 Repair Café en France,
ces lieux où on apprend soi-même
à réparer un grille-pain
ou à recoudre ses vêtements.
Partageons-nous les astuces,
les bons plans, les savoir-faire,
comme le fait si bien l’association
Zero Waste France.
Bref, chers amis,
partageons-nous le repas.
Et lorsqu’un produit sera
vraiment en fin de vie,
que sa mort sera inévitable,
alors le recyclage est une belle solution.
Figurez-vous que j’ai écrit
une lettre à Manu.
Je voulais vous la lire
avant de lui envoyer.
« Bravo et merci Manu de vouloir agir
pour un monde plus juste,
pour un monde moins pire.
Mais le recyclage ne peut pas être
la seule solution,
car recycler pollue
et pousse à la consommation.
Il y a plus écologique, n’est-ce pas ?
Alors Manu, réfléchissons ensemble
pour changer le système.
Revenons aux bases
du bon sens et du partage.
Et du haut de nos décharges, scandons
cet adage : Utilisons l’existant !
Partageons-nous cela,
réinventons notre présent.
La créativité nous sauvera. »
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)